Oh oh good morning my name is Adam Smith
calling from nobelprize.org the official
website of the nobel prize in story I'm
working it
we were ringing to offer our
congratulations and also to ask whether
we might be able to record just a two or
three minute interview with you we have
a tradition of speaking to all new
laureates on the day of the announcement
okay thank you very much well as I say
first of all our congratulations
and how did you hear the news that
you've been awarded the economics prize
how long ago was this just a few minutes
yeah what was your first reaction on
hearing the news have you have you ever
thought how you might react to this news
if you if it came I don't I didn't want
to ever presume that I would win so I
didn't really think about it a long time
and your work stems from work you did
during your PhD thesis exactly but you
studied French initially so what was it
that turned you on to the study of a
surprising I in my junior year in
college I switched I was getting kind of
tired of French and I so I took an
economics course and I loved it and like
the rest of my two years in college I
spent in economics and then I came to
University of Chicago got a PhD from the
Business School where I had the
privilege of having professors Merton
Miller and Harry Roberts and Lestat
elsens and while mandelberg coming
around
the work on effort prices was just
starting to warm up at that time so it
was a good area for a young person to
get into and this is yet another
economics prize for the University of
Chicago what is it about that the
environment there that's so productive
well we have good people you need that
obviously and this is very interactive
environments people help one another out
a lot I mean I couldn't do what I did
without the help of my professors at the
time and colleagues since then and
students since then it's a very
interactive place where everybody
contributes for everybody else
wonderful just let me ask you one more
question please the the prize will focus
attention on the area of asset pricing
very widely so of course your work is
very well-known to those in the finance
community but people have never
encountered this before will suddenly be
exposed to it what fundamentally would
you say was the relevance of your work
to the world at large well this
particular area it's really the idea is
really how do you measure risk and if
the market is pricing things correctly
what is the relation between the expect
expected return which is the
compensation for risk and risk okay
perfectly said thank you very much
indeed okay we look forward to speak
again soon thank you here at graduate
you